wouldn't it be great if every
you reached for an object in four
reality you could feel its shape surface
texture and force instead of a typical
buzzing and rumbling you get from
controllers today
well with our two novel handheld
controllers you can our first device
called normal touch haptically renders
object surfaces and provides force
feedback using a tilt table and extrude
about platform you can see how normal
touch keeps your finger tracing the
surface even if your hand movement is
not very steady
our second device called texture touch
features a 4x4 matrix of actuated pins
underneath the fingertip that
individually renders the 3d shape of
virtual objects including some structure
of the surface texture by moving our
devices around while keeping the finger
on the actuated platform users obtain
the sensation of a much larger 3d shape
by integrating output sensations over
time our haptic controllers are tracked
in 3d space using the optic tract
tracking system and we demonstrate them
with an oculus rift dk2 headset our
normal touch device senses the finger
force and can render force feedback
allowing the user to interact with
deformable objects and feel their
different surface stiffness
or a person can interact with a rigid
body physics simulation notice how you
can use the force sensing to flick the
ball around
to make it easier to remain in contact
with the surface when touching virtual
objects we implemented a penetration
compensation technique which prevents
the hand from penetrating the surface
the results of our experiments show that
the haptic shape output produced by our
controllers matched participants visual
experience better than the two baseline
conditions which provided vibrotactile
and visual only feedback overall with
our devices participants reported a more
realistic experience for more results
see the paper
so if you want to use handheld VR
controllers that also enable you to feel
the shape of virtual objects give our
normal touch and texture touch a try